[Music]  Dancing with the Stars season 24 is  nearly here here's what et has learned  about this year's pairings um I think uh  Sasha Simone biles got her wish a source  tells etz Olympian will be paired with  Sasha Farber our source also says the  plan is for fifth Harmony's normani  Corday to dance with Val Chmerkovskiy  and you can bet on Gliese Heather Morris  hitting the dance floor too I think it  would be fun you know who wouldn't want  to do it  bachelor Nick vile should get paired  with Peta Murgatroyd while Charo will  probably shake her stuff with Pio expect  to see mr. t dancing with Kim Johnson  SNL alum Chris Kattan will also compete  this year as well Real Housewives fan  favorite Erika Jayne our source says  she's partnered with Glenn you have to  wait much  you